c'est une lettre qualifiée d'honteuse le
ministre de l'éducation nationale n'a
pas mâché ces mots après la publication
d'un courrier du rectorat de Versailles
adressé aux parents de Nicolas dont le
suicide à Poissy avait provoqué
l'émotion le 5 septembre dernier en
réponse Gabriel Attal a décidé de
convoquer ce lundi l'ensemble des
recteurs le but lancé un audit national
sur l'ensemble des situations de
harcèlement qui ont été signalées
l'année passée alors que les parents du
collégien qui s'est donné la mort avait
alerté du harcèlement que subissait leur
fils le rectorat dans une lettre du 4
mai 2023 avait répondu en menaçant de
porter plainte contre la famille les
propos que vous avez tenus et le
comportement que vous avez eu en verre
des personnels de l'Éducation nationale
dont le professionnalisme et l'intégrité
n'avait pas être remise en cause de la
sorte sont inacceptables je les réprouve
de la façon la plus vive aussi dans
l'intérêt de votre enfant et par souci
d'exemplarité à son égard je vous
enjoins d'adopter désormais une attitude
constructive et respectueuse envers les
autres membres de la communauté
éducative et plus largement tout
personnel de l'éducation nationale qui
oeuvre à la prise en charge de votre
fils et agit au mieux à son égard rendu
public la réponse a été fermement
condamnée par le gouvernement qui a fait
de la lutte contre le harcèlement
scolaire sa grande cause contactez
l'académie de Versailles pour le moment
pas souhaité s'exprimer pour cette
représentante de parents d'élèves le
manque de considération pose problème de
ne pas avoir pris assez en compte
l'inquiétude de cette famille c'est ça
qui reprochable le contexte la situation
malheureusement ce drame n'avons pas à
jugement apporté sur la situation
cependant le fait que une famille évolue
alerter et voulu protéger son enfant ce
soit vu répondre avec aussi peu de
considération et surtout
finalement doivent maintenant
vivre sans leur son enfant ça c'est
inattendable ce n'est pas la première
fois que le rectorat de Versailles se
trouve au centre des critiques en
octobre 2020 à Conflans-Sainte-Honorine
l'assassinat de Samuel Paty avait déjà
mis en lumière des dysfonctionnements de
l'Académie dans une plainte déposée en
2022 par la famille de l'enseignant le
rectorat de Versailles est accusé de ne
pas avoir pris deux mesures de
protection malgré les signalements